Angelina Jolie makes her first public  appearance and splitting from husband  Brad Pitt's a family affair the 41 year  old actress and all six of her children  Maddux packs Zahara Shiloh and twins  Knox and Vivian traveled to Cambodia for  the premiere of the new Netflix original  film she directed and produced first  they killed my father I felt very very  lucky  Cambodia clearly means a lot to Angelina  as her adopted son Maddox is Cambodian  and the new movie tells the story of the  devastation caused by the Cambodian  Khmer Rouge Communist Party in the 1970s  we set the stage and we explained  Angelina looked happy as ever in a  beautiful black lace dress and matching  heels while her children looked equally  chic by her side  you